zemmour et naulleau le retour avec notre
grand témoin il est maire de pau il est
président du modem en 2012
il a voté pour françois hollande alors
quel bilan fait qu'il trois ans et demi
après c'est françois méro
soir afin de mieux vous connaître j'ai
un petit questionnaire à vous soumettre
c'est le qcm ce sera très rapide
marine le pen présidente s'est jouée
d'avancé comme le déclare malek boutih
ça finira par arriver comme le déclare
henri guaino ce n'est pas une fatalité
comme le déclare marielle de sarnez mais
pas une fatalité
pourquoi ce n'est pas une fatalité parce
que quand on pense que quelque chose est
dangereux risque est très mal pour à un
pays bas on se bat pour l'éviter quand
on se bat pour l'éviter on gagne très
bien
le grand vainqueur des régionales sera
le ps les républicains où le fn je ne
suis pas vous n'avez pas une petite idée
non à un pronostic blanche
je fais pas de pronostics c'est pas
c'est pas bon c'est pas mon sujet donc
vous n'avez pas peur du fn
en règle générale non je n'ai pas peur
du front national et même pour les
régionales le fait qu'il puisse
remporter deux régions pour quelques
échéances que ce soit je n'ai pas peur
du front national je pense qu'on ne se
bat pas contre lui comme il faudrait se
battra je pense que qu'on est impuissant
paralysé cette année inaudible
désespérant pour les gens je parle de la
vie politique traditionnelle comme elle
se développe comme je veux vous rappeler
j'ai je me suis battu contre elle depuis
longtemps d'anciens on va en scène on va
peut-être en parler mais pour le reste
non je n'ai pas peur au sens a eu peur
fasciné les gens sont fascinés par le
front national il regarde ça comme le
temps comme les prochains boa
constricteur moi je n'ai pas peur des
beaux arts et encore moins des
constructeurs très bien le meilleur âge
pour être président 71 ans soit salle 6
ans aux 48 ans alors le giscard me
disait autrefois exercé bien que j'ai
beaucoup fréquenté
valéry giscard d'estaing dont j'ai été
le bras droit pendant longtemps
il disait le meilleur âge pour être
député doit commencer par 1,3 pour être
ministre par 1,4 votre providence par un
cinq étoiles et pleines dents par 1,6
inutile de dire qu'à l'époque où il
disait ça son âge a lui commencé par un
6 mai il avait été président 48 en jeu
wii
c'était je pense qu'ils étaient trop
jeunes qui n'avaient pas le recul
nécessaire
vous savez dans ses fonctions il ya un
alcool très puissant et l'ébriété du
pouvoir il faut avoir beaucoup mûri pour
l'éviter enfin selon le président de
temps de giscard n'est plus du tout le
même que celui d'aujourd'hui là il a pas
il a pas le quart des pouvoirs qu'ils
avaient alors je me je ne partage
absolument pas cette idée germe eric
zemmour la défendre et je pense qu'elle
est complètement faux celui des derrick
st j'essaierai de montrer pourquoi
d'accord d'accord ça fera un débat assez
mais ce qu'eric zemmour dit est partagé
à peu près par la totalité de la classe
politique française et moi je ne partage
pas ce sentiment quand tous très bien
alors j'ai appelé parce que on n'a
peut-être pas compris armée 71 ans ce
sera l'âge d'alain juppé en 2010 16 66
le vôtre en 2007 et 48 ans celui corps à
marine le pen
j'ai une dernière question à vous poser
la boulette que vous ne leur ferai plus
jamais c'est soutenir la droite alors
qu'aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy sait
nicolas sarkozy à qui préside les
républicains c'est voter à gauche c'est
vous représenter à l'élection
présidentielle je n'ai jamais voté à
gauche au sens accord avec le parti se
réabonner soutenir françois hollande
j'ai choisi à titre personnel alternance
en 2017 en 2012 j'ai choisi l'alternance
nous habitue ces jeunes aiment choisir
m6 en 2010 est l'alternance était tout à
fait parce que c'est ma liberté de
citoyen mais bien c'est exactement là
vaut absolument absolument je suis
d'accord si je si je faisais un peu de
2,2
et introspection d'introspection se
dérouler peut-être on aurait des
surprises sur le bulletin que vous avez
déposé et donc moi en tout cas j'assume
de manière absolument clair en 2012 j'ai
considéré que sarkozy entraîner la
france dans une direction qui était une
direction très très très très choquant
j'ai donc voté contre lui je n'ai pas
fait d'accord avec le ps la preuve c'est
que le ps m'a fait battre à l'élection
suivante et après tout il avait
parfaitement le droit puisque je n'étais
pas dans un accord avec eux et donc non
je j'ai choisi l'alternance et j'ai tout
à fait la liberté chaque fois qu'il ya
un scrutin on a la liberté de s'exprimer
cantonnet un citoyen ce que je suis
merci merci beaucoup
françois bayrou pour ses réponses
concises alors dans un petit peu plus
sur vous grâce à ce questionnaire je
vous laisse découvrir ce que un petit
peu quand même découvrir ce que vous
n'êtes pas c'est lent qui portraits
réalisés par dimitri queffélec tout le
monde dans cette affaire non candidat
sarkozy candidat sarkozy dit à nous les
baisses d'impôts tu parles
lorsqu'on a été au pouvoir on les
augmenter de 120 milliards françois
hollande s'est fait élire en faisant de
grandes déclarations sur le fait qu'il
ne ferait pas de privatisation
il en est à 120 milliards de
privatisations fait bayrou hollande
sarkozy son sort en plateau c'était en
1999 lors des élections européennes et
déjà françois bayrou après avoir été
ministre de l'éducation sous trois
gouvernements de droite
aucune formation n'échappait plus à vos
critiques
certains disent les mêmes choses avec
les mêmes mots ici comme ensemble juste
un homme libre qui n'est jamais été
coincés dans les contingences partisanes
la gauche la droite si vous avez annoncé
voter françois hollande pour le second
tour de la présidentielle de 2012
aujourd'hui votre préférence se tourner
vers alain juppé j'ai pour alain juppé
beaucoup destiné aux revirements et
prises de position vous ne vous êtes pas
fait que des amis
françois bayrou à droite on ne vous juge
pas toujours lisible il a commis un
crime de lèse sarkozy qui lui vaut
désormais une volonté un désir de
vengeance d'une partie de l'électorat de
droite ni françois bayroux il est
partout et nulle part il est surtout
nulle part d'ailleurs je reconnais que
le centre est sans doute un peu
compliqué à trouver parfois aujourd'hui
il porte une part de la responsabilité
de ce que fait françois hollande
hollande avait des atours 2012 il avait
pris des engagements et ses engagements
il ne les a pas respectées
ancien député au parlement de strasbourg
c'est surtout l'europe qui dans la
lignée du centre français et reste le
fil rouge de votre parcours vous la
décrivez comme la clé pour peser sur
l'avenir du monde
françois bayrou vous est tout sauf
eurosceptiques on essaie de faire croire
aux français que l'europe les menaces la
réalité est que l'europe les protège
c'est leur seule arme
françois bayrou est évidemment un
européen sans doute à fédéraliste mais
ces engagements là ils sont devenus
terriblement impopulaire on est assis
sur une bombe alors les européens les
européistes y met le drapeau dans leur
poche s'il y a bien chez vous une
qualité que personne ne peut nier c'est
enfin celle de toujours essayer être le
chef de l'état voilà votre objectif déjà
trois tentatives pour y parvenir
peut-être une quatrième si sarkozy qu'à
la primaire en novembre 2016 françois
bayrou sera candidat car françois bayrou
vous n'êtes pas résignés et ne s'use que
si l'on s'en sert mais comme ça n'a pas
servi beaucoup il n'est pas précisé
quand il peut être un nouveau candidat
système rayon la république peut être
premier ministre il jouera cette carte à
fond
un vote controversé un centre difficile
à faire exister mais des ambitions
toujours élevé voilà pourquoi françois
bayrou il fallait vous inviter
eh bien ça mérite que l'on parle et pour
commencer ce débat monsieur bayrou
eric naulleau a quelque chose à vous
dire oui elle va d'abord que l'on est
très heureux de vous recevoir vous étiez
invité de la première de zemmour et
naulleau vous êtes l'invité de la 110e
et nous est même venu entre temps et en
l'honneur de ces trois invitations
j'ai sélectionné trois raisons pour
lesquelles vous ne serez pas le prochain
président de la république je voudrais
vous réagissiez successivement à chacune
de ces propositions alors premier point
ça ne vous a pas échappé en observant ce
moment une poussée aux extrêmes alors à
l'extrême droite avec la montée du fn et
la droitisation des esprits dont
certains de mes voisins ne sont pas tout
à fait innocent et à l'extrême gauche et
frondeur du ps et la gauche de la gauche
qui voudrait une autre politique donc
première objection le centre les plus
une idée pour le présent et sans doute
plus une idée pour l'avenir proche
première objection à laquelle je vous
laisse répondre
est ce qu'il ya une poussée vers les
extrêmes où oui est ce que cette poussée
vers les extrêmes est bonne elle est
catastrophique et donc comme elle est
catastrophique
il faut bien qu'il y ait des gens pour
proposer un autre avenir
un autre câble pour le pays basque c'est
d'une simplicité biblique donc votre
argument pour moi il va à l'encontre de
ce que vous dites ça du coup votre
espace se réduit puisque les gens
mettent des électeurs pour dire les
choses plus précisément son algérie ce
que je puis vous dire quelque chose
votre intervention là ça repose sur
l'idée d'ailleurs c'était aussi dans ces
jeunes induits susurré dans le dans le
sujet que le rêve de ma vie serait
d'être président de la république
ça fait quand même présenté trois fois
comme comme tous françois le nicolas
sarkozy son rêve
et de se présenter pour la troisième
fois bon ben voilà c'est c'est comme ça
et et d'autres se sont présentés souvent
j'observe d'ailleurs que c'est souvent à
la fin qu'ils ont fait le meilleur score
pourrait laisser - votre ambition que le
centrisme montant est tel que j'en
attendais donc premier point moi ça n'a
jamais été l'ambition de ma vie j'ai
d'autres ambitions
j'espère écrire de bons livres vrai
jespere ça je suis sûr avoir des enfants
formidables
j'espère j'espère entraîné le béarnais
et la ville de pau qui l'incarnent vers
un horizon meilleur ça et j'espère être
pour une famille politique qui pour moi
est crucial pour le pays
quelqu'un qu'il incarne et qui la
portent et qui si besoin la fera
renaître
voilà ça c'est des règles de vie après
c'était président d'avenir les
le président de la république je vais je
vais vous dire quelque chose je n'ai
jamais pensé qu'être président ça
rendait heureux c'est pas que je lance
un tout petit quand je pense à peu près
là c'est pas fait pareil à des
circonstances pour un pays pour la vie
d'un pays où on a la responsabilité le
devoir sans vouloir employer deux grands
bon d'être là parce que personne n'est
là sur la sur la ligne que ta voix
défendent est-ce que je crois nécessaire
dont on va parler c'est tout il n'ya il
n'y a personne qui est le à mon sens
cela juste vision et donc on est obligé
de voter contre pour l'un contre l'autre
en 2000 pour la en dépit des doutes
qu'on a sur lui
simplement pour éviter l'autre et ceci
est catastrophique et vous ne cherchez
pas plus loin une des raisons de la
désaffection des gens pourquoi il se
détourne pas parce qu'ils sont toujours
obligés de voter contre
ils n'ont pas l'offre politique
nécessaire ils ont failli l'avoir en
je vous propose c'est un de bruxelles
qui s'est passé quelque chose entre la
version longue je vais laisser zemmour
intervenir à chaque point parce que
sinon il va non mais moi je voulais j'ai
écouté ce que vous ne changiez sur
effectivement vous n'êtes pas le seul à
vous est présenté trois fois il ya eu
chirac ou mitterrand sarkozy ça va trois
fois tout ça vous avez tout à fait
raison
sauf que vous nous avez vous nous
expliquer souvent vous est d'ailleurs
vous n'êtes pas le seul que nous devons
limiter les allemands les anglais
d'autres pays pour leur capacité de
réforme et c'est ça vous le répétez
souvent aux français et vous ça ne vous
aura pas échappé que dans ces pays là
quand un leader politique perd une
élection il se retire et on n'entend
plus parler de lui donc pourquoi la
classe politique française le donner des
leçons français ni mythes tels pas les
classes politiques européennes
puisqu'elle est toujours admirer les
belles et pourquoi ce sont les mêmes
journalistes depuis 30 ans mais moi je
veux pas irriter les pays où les livres
y compris vous et moi je veux pas imiter
les autres moyens plus je n'ai pas je ne
sais si vous vous expliquer en français
qu'il faut réformer comme les autres
églises et moi vous vous trompez et on
va en parler mais n'essayez pas de
mélanger les questions à six et la même
quête le vous êtes vous eric zemmour en
particulier on se connaît depuis 55 ans
dans les années 80 peut-être un peu plus
voilà presque 30 ans vous êtes là depuis
trente ans est ce que vous étiez aussi
percutant il ya 30 ans non est ce que
est ce que vous avez approfondies je ne
crois pas que votre ligne soit juste
mais je reconnais l'impact est ce que
vous avez approfondie depuis 30 ans oui
est ce que moi je pensais aussi
clairement il ya 30 ans non moi je dis
le contraire
et bien voilà vous répondre
pas le contraire alors dit je suis
d'accord avec nova c'est une très bonne
raison sauf qu'elle ne répond pas à la
question
ben si elles réclament georges marchais
vous avez votre réponse et j'ai mes
canons elle répond complètement dans les
autres pays
vous seriez retiré depuis longtemps oui
ou ce que je disais mais dans les autres
pays à un autre système est comme vous
savez il ya la représentation
proportionnelle mis tous les pays allant
chez elle mais vrai que voilà j'aimerais
vous entendre dire ça pour le reste de
la politique dans les autres pays il ya
un autre système
et bien voilà dans les autres pays à
notre système allant d'ailleurs on va
entrer tout à l'heure voilà dans le
débat oui et vous me permettrez de vous
rappeler ce que je suis en train de dire
ici la question française elle n'est pas
la question des autres pays on est bien
d'accord
et donc on voit un européen qui disent
ah mais oui je peins parce que qu'est-ce
que c'est europe c'est de refuser la
solitude d'un pays mais on n'est jamais
on ne sait pas vrai mais on ne peut pas
résoudre vous lancer sa ligne et aux
pieds vous savez très bien et bien alors
expliquez ça à vos lecteurs n'est pas du
tout jamais mais rudy salles ou vous
laisser longtemps va d'une vous insinuez
exactement le contraire votre europe
fédérale est devenue la machine des
oligarques est ce que vous mangez dirige
le rang que vous savez dragon poyer le
mohair fédéral on reprend pas réglo et
eric naulleau
donnez-moi acte des mots que j'utilise
et donc nous allons approfondir cette
question deuxième point numéro à mon
avis on ne peut pas se faire élire
président suffrage universel sur un
langage de vérité dont vous vous êtes
c'est une spécialité donc ma deuxième
objection c'est que vous ne serez jamais
élu au suffrage universel parce que je
crois vous vous rapprochez également de
2,2 fillon qui nous a inventé ici sa
rupture libérale
moi je prétends que les français ne sont
n'attendent pas une rupture ribera leur
jeu on peut pas sauver des gens des
promesses raisonnable on perd et livre
traite exactement de ce sujet il
s'appelle de la vérité en politique
absolument
est ce que soutient le livre c'est que
tous ceux qui racontent qu'on ne peut
pas se faire élire en disant la vérité
devrait avoir à l'esprit
ceci qui est maintenant vérifier par
tous le monde sait qu'on ne peut pas
gouverner sur n'a pas dit la vérité
et ça change rien c'est plus facile de
se faire élire pour se faire élire de
raconter des histoires mais simplement
vous ne pouvez pas de gouverner je vais
gouverner faut se faire élire
je reconnais que je raconte dans
l'introduction de ce livre une scène
pour moi fascinante
on est en en 1936 et au parlement
britannique churchill
à l'époque le plus impopulaire de toul
et de tous les hommes politiques
britanniques parce que il les passait
d'un là il a changé de bord il est donc
devenu impopulaire dans tous les bords
ce qui peut arriver et donc cherche il
se lève et ils interpellent le premier
ministre de l'époque en lui disant
pourquoi alors que vous connaissiez la
vérité de ce que l'allemagne est elle en
train de faire avez vous fait campagne
électorale sur le désarmement du pays et
le premier ministre va pour lui répondre
légumes ce churchill je vais je vais
vous répondre
c'est le mot qui l'utilisent avec une
effroyable sincérité
j'étais chef d'un grand parti l'opinion
publique était profondément pacifiste je
ne pouvais pas aller aux élections en
disant la vérité contre le sentiment du
peuple
et cet homme a pris la responsabilité de
faire disparaître son pays pour gagner
une élection eh bien pour moi c'est
quelque chose diège un possible un
insupportable
et en effet je prétends que le/la
proches dont on a besoin c'est des gens
qui un voie la vérité
deux disent la vérité 3-1 vente et c'est
pas si facile sur des chemins différents
pour entraîner leurs pays hors du
gouffre où il se trompèrent examen
aurait beaucoup à dire sur cette
séquence historique mais on n'est pas là
pour se distraire en 36 by aurait
beaucoup à dire y aurait beaucoup à dire
parce que l'angleterre en 36 en fait est
de mèche avec l'allemagne et la france
la l'angleterre veut laisser l'allemagne
à battre la puissance française
définitivement musée - de l'europe c'est
pas le pacifisme l'opinion que c'est des
mensonges ne fait pas le cas aujourd'hui
dans l'histoire je vous sortie de
quelque chose qui est qui monsieur
bayrou il y a aujourd'hui les amenant
l'essai or quand vous dites il
la réponse de françois bayrou quand vous
dites l'angleterre il sait exactement
comme si vous disiez la france entre 40
et 44 voulait que il y avait peut-être
moins occupé les bienveillantes être des
restes qui roulait heureusement que ce
n'est pas le débat mais qui a volé de
jeu par mois il y avait peut-être des
responsables politiques y en avait qui
rêvait jeu ça mais vous ne pouvez pas
dire l'angleterre je vous sens du peuple
eh ben vous auriez c'est le monde mais
c'est impossible mais vous investissez
du coup pas très bien vous en parlerez
on en parle
deuxièmement il ya quelque chose que je
comprends pas normalement
moi quand je fais des livres j'essaie de
décrire mes livres le mieux possible
beau aussi donc j'imagine que quand on
fait de la politique on essaye d'en
faire le mieux possible
il ne s'agit pas de vérités de mensonges
il s'agit d'être bon
quand le général de gaulle revient au
pouvoir en 58 il ment à tout le monde et
ça donne le général de gaulle il ya
parfois des mensonges utile il faut
arrêter avec cette fausse naïveté en
plus l'important politique c'est de
réussir pour le pays bien sûr vous je me
permets pas de ne donner le son je joue
simplement je fais des constats vous
êtes l'incarnation de ce que mauriac ap
la maladresse des habile en 2007
vous tendez la vous n'attendez pas la
main à ségolène royal alors qu'elle a
besoin de vous voulu claquer la porte au
nez alors que vous aviez les moyens de
détruire de diviser la gauche et de
prendre vraiment
pouvoir pour le bien du pays et en 2012
vous fait l' inverse quand hollande n'a
pas besoin de vous vous lui tendez la
main et c'est vous qui prenez la porte
dans la tronche
donc moi j'aimerais comprendre ce qui
vous ce qui vous guide ce qui vous mène
là vous me dites que vous soutenez juppé
et vous me rappelez exactement la phrase
de charles pasqua qu'on a très bien
connu au fond et moi qui ai avec des
amis comme ça j'ai pas besoin d'ennemis
vous soutenez juppé comme la corde
soutient le pendu vous savez très bien
que votre soutien le plombe auprès des
électeurs de droite qui vous ont pas
pardonné votre soutien à hollande
et vous savez très bien en plus que
juppé s'il perd c'est votre seule chance
puisque vous pourrez alors vous vous
présentez dont carey leur part les
vérités de sincérité et c'est l'agencé
depuis longtemps c'est vrai qu'on n'a
pas parlé depuis longtemps je vous ai
connu là vous rattraper dieu je vous ai
connu sensible honnête dans vos
jugements
et c'est parce que vous êtes en train de
faire alors j'aimerais ça du ton le plus
le plus malaisée à les y répondent m
pourquoi je soutiens juppé parce que je
pense qu'il est dans la situation où
qu'il est en situation pour faire que la
politique française fonctionne
différemment parce qu'il n'est pas chef
de parti parce que les deux parties le
fil de fer avec le ps et l'ump
essayez de ne pas être simpliste j'aime
bien quand quand on fait cet effort 1
donc ça fait deux fois dans l'est dans
l'émission que vous proférez des choses
qui sont un peu simple moi c'est pas
simple mais c'est une réaction ce qu'on
taxe les et moi je vais essayer d'aller
est ce que on vit sous l' empire comme
andy rey dans la langue classique on vit
sous
le sous le règne de deux parties qui
sont depuis trop longtemps dont les
appareils sont depuis trop longtemps en
intimité avec la présidence de la
république
je considère que c'est une erreur je
pense qu'il faut faire échapper la
france à cette fatalité là en cela je ne
fais que dire à ma manière
aujourd'hui ce que le général de gaulle
disait d après la guerre c'est là qu'est
ce que dit le discours de bayeux
discours de bayeux pour les auditeurs
c'est 45 le grand discours en 1947 ou de
gaulle disent que deux doivent de il a
refusé la 4ème république il est parti
au nom de la vérité
il a accepté d'être battu puisqu'il va
être après la mine et comme parti
quelques années après et non d'abord les
prix dans le bon et donc de gaulle
qu'est ce qui dit il dit il faut que le
gouvernement échappe au jeu des partis
qu'il ne procède plus des combinaisons
parlementaire et qu'il procède du
président de la république qui sera
au-dessus départ et aujourd'hui ils ont
récupéré tout ça et aux gens les deux
parties ont tous récupéré d'accord et
mon jeu est là et la proposition que je
fais que je considère comme
indispensable et nécessaire au pays et
que je défendrai mordicus c'est qu'il
faut précisément qu'on rompe avec cette
dépendance
juppé vous aussi vous avez écrit des
bêtises quand vous étiez
bon ben aujourd'hui peut-être vous
essayez d'en écrire moi il a sur ce
point changé il a échappé aux appareils
il a payé un prix assez lourd pour
précisément être en dehors des appareils
donc il a payé judiciairement il a
depuis la mairie j'ai dirigé une grande
ville il a il a appris à être plus enfin
j'espère peu différent et il est en
situation et c'est pourquoi je dis qu'on
venait avec moi que c'est assez rare de
responsables politiques as un socle
électoral important
disent écoutez moi je suis prêt à le
mettre à disposition de quelqu'un qui
pourra ou dont j'espère qu'il pourra
donc j'espère qu'il voudra changer les
choses c'est ce que je fais et c'est
pourquoi il n'ya là dedans aucune
habileté
il n'ya là dans aucune ruse si j'avais
voulu rusé si si mon obsession était
d'être candidat à la présidence de la
république comme comme vous l'insinuez
va il suffisait que je le dise non je
n'en pense personne je ne dépends de
personne
simplement ce temps je dis je suis prêt
à l'aider c'est vrai et réel et est
alors du coup monsieur bo est ce que
vous regrettez d'avoir personnellement
voter pour françois hollande
je ne regrette jamais les décisions que
je prends conscience on va vous recrutez
ça n'a pas tenu ses engagements
est ce que françois hollande a tenu les
engagements qu'il avait pris
est ce qu'il a été à la hauteur de ce
qu'il avait dit en rien mais c'est pas
vrai aurait alors besoin je fais pas moi
il a rien été les gars là où il y avait
60 promesses sachant que quelques-unes
alors on l'aurait je détaille je vais en
prendre quelques unes ouais remess
essentiel dès 2015
je réduirai le déficit du pays ou de son
2 3% et sacré en 2006 et en 2017 nous
serons à 0 nous serons à l'équilibré
procès bayrou il a essayé il a augmenté
les impôts oui mais ben écoutez
franchement sommet
la boutade il ya quelque chose de
sérieux vous avez compris non mais si il
a fait sa méthode à l'unesco il a il n'a
pas tenu sa promesse
je parle pas des promesses sur l'emploi
parce que tout le monde voit ce qu elles
sont je vous rappelle qu'il dit moi
président de la république c'est dans la
liste je ne recevrai pas les partis
politiques à l'elysée parce que je veux
pas me mêler de ce genre il a reçu ben
bennahmias 9 x ou dix fois paraît-il
il y à il a plongé les deux mains jusqu
aux omoplates dans la tambouille
politique alors que la fonction
présidentielle aurait dû à mes yeux les
cartons
enfin il pas dit
la même chose l'un a plus de valeur que
l'autre la grande tirade a plus de
valeur aux yeux
il y avait 15 millions ou 21 heures
qu'ils ont vu moi je suis un homme a
écrit comme vous et enfin et enfin il
dit dans la grande tirade mois président
de la république
j'installerai la proportionnelle parce
que je veux que toutes les opinions
soient représentés au parlement comme
at-il fait rien donc le en même temps
c'est prône le changement lance en solo
mais vous vous n'en saurez vous vous en
faisiez qui reçoivent pas les noix les
prêts excusez mon parti tout le monde
s'en trouve ça n'est pas parce qu'eric
zemmour s'en fout que le pays où
l'intérêt mais il y aura quelque chose
c'est que on vous entend parler je n'ai
pas fini ma fille n'avait jamais filmé
sur les rouges et donc le changement de
pratiques politiques
aucun et pour résumer ce que je pense au
fond françois hollande a cru que la
fonction de président de la république
était une fonction politique du même
ordre que premier secrétaire du ps
et la vérité c'est que c'est une
fonction historique vous avez largement
anticipée demande il n'est pas président
comment savoir l'était pas eh bien nous
allons sur ces deux points nous sommes
anéantis si tu es mon troisième point
qui était le suivant vous ne pourrez de
candidats que si alain juppé n'est pas
hors jeu qu'on ce qu'alain juppé va
remporter les primaires de l'ump laisse
un gros pari que je votre place est
prise alors est elle bien pris soin je
vous écoute depuis divisée et je ne vois
pas ce que c'est que le judaïsme on dit
il a payé le prix fort pour s'éloigner
des partis c'est un éloignement
judiciaire c'était pas un éloignement
politique qui en quoi consiste le
judaïsme revivre revu à la sauce bayrou
pourquoi moi je voterais pour pour juppé
à la prochaine saison je ne sais pas
vous le regret de dire qu'il allait
remporter la primaire oui je vous avait
des raisons de penser je pense qu'il
incarne la dernière chance qu'on a d'une
france un peu apaisé les gens voient la
seringue
les plus lourds et si vous êtes dans le
pacifisme que monsieur bayrou c'est
parce qu'on les hait naîtront à ce que
le nom parce que les français sont un
peu dans le genre au moins réfléchir à
qui se passait rien mais c'est être en
tribunes et voilà mais attendez qu'on
s'assied et bien su seymour eric oui
ramener l'eau l'argent voilà et laquelle
mouvementée où il faut mesurer ce conte
henry est encore davantage ce qu'on dit
la phrase que vous venez lire
elle signifie que mon soutien à juppé
est du même ordre que ceux qui voulaient
désarmé l'angleterre en face de hitler
je pense que il y a des moments
historiques absolument g où le pacifisme
devient je suis pas pacifiste
on va voir j'ai pas mis l'occasion d'y
dont le dit que juste b juppé avec
c'était sur l'identité heureuse et sa
volonté d'accommodements raisonnables
avec l'islam et digne un passif mais je
ne vais pas les autres on parlait de
juppé vous avez contesté vivement et
talentueusement la réforme des collèges
vous aurez remarqué que dans son dernier
livre sur l'éducation juppé copie
presque mot à mot
cette réforme qu'est ce que vous faites
là dedans jamais personne avait coincé
directement sur ce sujet vous venez de
le faire parce que vous avez raison je
suis sur ce point en désaccord avec lui
je considère que la réforme du collège
est une catastrophe merci mon cv
d'accord ce que c'est que vous serez pas
le syndicat attendait j'ai pas fini la
réponse que c'est une atteinte profonde
à l'idée que nous nous faisons de
l'école républicaine
elle nous a fait vous et moi ce que nous
physiquement on est bien d'accord y
compris parce que le gouvernement wray
d'un trait de plume le latin le grec
partie de l'histoire par vous que je
vais apprendre que c'est la fin du
boulot où elle finit le boulot depuis un
brouillard entendent de ces gens qui est
l'école moi je les envie là moi mais oui
dont françois debré fils l'inter en 5
mais moi je suis d'accord moi même comme
chevènement essayer aussi de tâches au
sein de mon côté je vais le mot et moi
on a ici je suis d'accord voilà bien
c'est sur la longue durée vous avez bien
l'aventuré
peut-être nous n'avons pas pour
l'instant gagné la guerre mercier nous
avons l'intention de livrer la bataille
très bien j'aime dernière avec juppé
attendaient attendez ce n'est pas fini
il ya pas de réponse
si si je viens de les résoudre avec mon
nom je je je pense que sur ce point il a
rien fait votre diagnostic est exams est
ce que juppé à 10 et je publie un
ouvrage pour ouvrir le débat
j'écouterai ce qu'on me dira et sur ce
point j'ai bien l'intention en effet bon
d'avoir avec lui les explications
nécessaires parce que je considère je
vais aller encore plus loin que eric
zemmour je considère que l'un des enjeux
majeurs de la prochaine élection
présidentielle c'est la question de
l'école d'équitation
on est daniel dans vos réponses je
n'entends pas réponse à ma question
alain juppé est il autre chose que le
recours pour tous les gens de droite qui
ne veulent plus de sarkozy
moi je vois comme ça je vois pas ce que
c'est que le judaïsme voir sur quelles
grandes idées et on a des regrets à
alain juppé pas si mal
c'est par darcy recherché par défaut si
vous cherchez à grande idée de nicolas
sarkozy ou de tel autre ou dotés n'a pas
non plus fait du mal
j'espère que vous en trouverez chez moi
et d'ailleurs ce que nous ont réservé
aux relations avec nicolas sarkozy ça
arrange pas du tout une sarrance groupe
a mais ça supposerait que
les sentiments que j'ai à l'égard de
nicolas sarkozy ou qu'il a à mon endroit
sont des sentiments personnels mais je
vous assure que c'est pas vrai j'ai
peine à vous croire
et ben oui mais bon joueur peut-être je
sais quand je parle
vous voyez extrême c'est dans cette
vision par exemple qui part donc s comme
françois fillon par exemple qu'à
quelques griefs alors j'ai pas de griefs
je suis en contradiction avec la proche
de la politique qui a été la sienne
depuis sept ou huit ans et qui est
encore la sienne aujourd'hui je suis en
confrontation d'accord je suis en en
affrontement avec cette position parce
que je pense qu'il n'y a rien de pire à
faire dans un pays qui traverse la crise
sur laquelle nous sommes que de jeter de
l'huile sur le feu pour se faire élire
parce que le la stratégie de nicolas
sarkozy elle repose sur l'idée que
fusent plus dont déchaîne les passions
plus on monte dans le dans les
intentions de vote et je ne partage pas
ce sentiment
enfin je sens que c'est ce dont je pense
que cet arrêt excusez moi mais je pense
que c'est vrai oui mais c'est un trop
grand risque sauf que ça ne marche
qu'une très bien passé plusieurs fois
maintenant ils sont complètement
déniaiser et c'est pour ça qu'un futur
elle est bien merci beaucoup merci c'est
déjà la fin de ce débat s'est passé très
vite mais bien sûr si j'avais plein de
questions mais on accueille en mai
laissez-moi ne laissez moi parce qu'on
avait esquissé quelque chose il est
temps que je dise
en une phrase en une phrase que je suis
en contradiction avec avec eric zemmour
sur un point fondamental
oui eric zemmour il prétend il affirme
et d'autres avec lui et toute une partie
de la droite et tout l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche que c'est l'europe qui
est la cause de nos faiblesses
hi hi hi han à partir de bruxelles qui a
pas de pouvoir en france
or aucun des sujets que nous avons à
aborder et qui sont la cause de notre
malheur national
aucun de ces sujets n'a été entraînés ou
légers
par l'europe ni l'éducation ni le droit
du travail ni le statut de l'entreprise
ni notre dépense publique
rien de tout ça n'a été provoqué par
l'europe alors vraiment en leur langue a
fait d accord en parfait désaccord
nos problèmes sont français sont pas
aucun sont pas mondiaux je ne dis pas
qu'ils y en texte mondial facile mais
nos problèmes sont français tout ce
qu'on a décrit tout au long de
l'émission
l'impuissance des pouvoirs la manière
désastreuse dont on mène la politique
rien tout ça n'était européen c'est nous
c'est nous en france qui s'avèrent les
responsables et bien être
on a deux noms paul compris culte et et
c'est en france qu'il faut qu'on les
corrige divisé sait où les chercher mon
la possibilité de revenir ici
voilà merci beaucoup